finally in person damona hoffman
[Applause]
jamona i've never done this segment
without you we've done it several times
um but the very first time we met you
mentioned the digital hankie which is
what we conduct you shifted my
perspective with that beautiful pairing
of words digital hanky thank you okay
according to a report from tinder gen z
has changed the future of dating with
their new interest in digital dates and
demona do you agree that digital dates
are here to stay
definitely and i also agree that they're
not just for gen z
everyone is adopting digital dating
because obviously you kind of had to
yeah i have always recommended it as a
screening step so that's what i think
might change people are now using it as
a replacement for the date but if you
can use it as a screening step keep it
short and sweet and then you know get
prepared for it like you would for a
regular date you know sometimes people
are like i'll just do a quick
quick little facetime date and then they
don't think about that's their first
impression that's the first time
someone's going to see them so if you
think of your lighting you think of like
not having our dirty underwear in the
back
and really set the stage for a great
meet cute it can still work in the
digital space well let's chat with two
women of different ages looking to
better their online dating game please
welcome amy and allison
[Applause]
okay so amy tell me what's going on in
your dating life well
i'm exhausted i've got the digital
burnout um i dated really really heavily
in my 20s and my 30s and i've been on
the apps all of that time and the dating
pool is just getting really shallow
um
actually so shallow i'm in repeats
that
i mean
is this a samantha jones moment where
you're like i've been with you before
this is yes in 2016 i went out with this
guy and it didn't you know didn't go
well we didn't really hit it off and
then in 2019 i went out with the same
guy
and we didn't realize that we'd been out
with each other until we were halfway
through the date
um when you did realize it could i ask
what you guys said or did um
i think we just said
[Laughter]
and then we just continued
we just continued on our on our date and
we we ended up having a good time the
second time around
maybe keeping an open mind is a good
thing
but don't ask me ask dimona
yeah damona how do i keep dating fun
because right now it's kind of a drag
i'm just i'm exhausted how does this
stay fun i hear that burnout and i
what i see here is by having so many
options it actually brings up anxiety it
takes the fun out of it right yeah and
it makes you not want to do it anymore
so i'm going to give you some advice
that may be a little counter-intuitive
okay i'm going to have you pull back
how many hours a day would you say you
spend on your dating um
probably two or three well if you are on
the apps for that much time
you're nothing's gonna look good to you
anymore right so i want you to limit the
time that you're spending on apps i'm
gonna give you 15 minutes a day that's
it because that will force you to make a
choice and not just keep swiping and
looking for the next best thing
and the other thing i want you to try is
something i call cycling so this is when
you start on one dating app take all of
the other apps off your phone and spend
four to six weeks on that one app and
then after four to six weeks you can go
to another app and then you get boosted
in the algorithm because you're new
everyone you see there is is new and
shiny you can get really excited again
and that cycling gives you a fresh
perspective and new options that you
might not have seen before
i like that that's a really interesting
thing that i've never tried before
i learned so much with you demona it
like crushes my soul in the best way
ever
[Music]